Continental Tire Coach's Corner brings
us the former Oklahoma head coach Bob
Stoops announced his retirement and kind
of surprised a lot of people there coach
let's bring in the Bob Stoops who joins
us now when's the last time you weren't
a coach at any point in your life well
then that would have been that would
have been the year I was graduating
college in Moncton 1982 so it's been a
long time how does it feel to not have a
job um you know it's uh it feels fine
right now but I think that the hard part
will be from August September when
you're used to for 30-some odd years you
know we there were 40 50 years always
being not being a part of the team
that'll be the hard part you know and
and um you know go on the practicing the
players everyday that'll be strange but
you know as I said my press conference
or in my statement you know life changes
Sunday you just got to keep rolling with
it how concerned are you about those
Saturdays in the fall of what to do I'm
not concerned that you know I didn't
come come to this decision for sure
lightly you know that it's been well
thought out and a lot of a lot of
sleepless nights and you know to be sure
you're doing the right thing for
yourself in the program and I am I'm I
don't have any regret whatsoever I know
it's the right time and the right thing
to do and and again you know everything
else it's has disease and uh you know
when the season comes around this this
year we'll see how it goes but I'll be
fine
one way or another I will be what
changed from last June when you got the
contract extension to this dude uh
nothing changed other than 111 more
games and ended up the top five team in
the country and another big 12
championship and want a sugar bowl
outside of that you know I've been you
know I've had a pretty good routine
through you know throughout my career
and feel like I've been well balanced
and the way I manage my family and my in
my work duties those kind of
think so it isn't it isn't that I needed
to do more of that it isn't that I was
burned out none of that it was just
simply the correct time with one can
Riley able to take it over and one for
me to be able to step away and it could
continue just as it has been when you
bringing this up to your wife ah that's
personal you know I gave I gave her a
little heads-up of course well I had
everyone else that this is something all
that keeps you know that keeps coming up
in my mind and and she was shocked of
course but understood no talking to go
coach stoops the Continental Tire
coaches cornered today when you look at
the whole process here of at age 56 now
the first thought is you know as young
as you are as successful as you are
stepping down is their health reasons is
there something to do with you know the
football team or off the field I mean
that's I guess the natural reaction so
was it sure was it any of those things
no there isn't there is no smoking gun
whatsoever
anyone who knows me knows that would
that's the case muffin muffin
health-wise you know like like everybody
I guess at my age you have your your
your your hearing more health battles
but there isn't anything serious or
imminent my at all and no smoking gun
anywhere it's just I guess people have a
hard time when someone just makes the
decision to handle their life the way
they want to and in step away in a
proper fashion and on something off it's
so good but that that really is just
just the way it is when you get another
job what kind of job will it be I'm sure
Monsoor were you know where this will
take me I'm on the big believer that doe
until you can open yourself up to
something um you know you got allowed to
come to you so I'm anxious to see you
know what you know what opportunities
will be there I will say I it isn't I'm
not it is
my intention to coach again Bob but but
we'll see what else comes broadcasting
possibly you know that you know I
appreciate respect what you guys all
have done you know through the years and
so who knows uh maybe your dad dying in
54 does that play any role in this
decision you being I think 56 now well I
think it's something that I've always
had to consider my in truth be told I I
you know I have a little bit of heart
disease that I've dealt with for a long
time you know 10 15 or so but it isn't
again it isn't anything that hasn't been
paid attention to and anything that
isn't in control but you know but that
you know that the fact that I did lose
my father at such a young age I can't
say does it you know doesn't enter your
mind here and there or doesn't have a
little bit to do with what you know what
I'm doing right now what haven't you
done in the last 30 years
that you want to do I can't say that
there's much of anything I've been so
fortunate so blessed
well maybe travel a little more maybe a
little bit more of your own time you
know just have a little bit more of your
own time I guess is is would be the the
one thing that that sometimes in our job
you get you know it's a seven day a week
and and you're you're constantly on call
for everything that you know maybe that
that part of it just to have a little
bit more growth talk but no sporting
event or nothing like that that you
didn't get a chance to go to because it
interfered well college football oh no I
can't remember the last time I have been
to a football game as a spectator Kirk
so and I love I love college football
evolved you know I love the game so you
got to do some tailgating coach yeah
I've never never tailgated never became
a spectator so they have to buy an RV
and then learn how to tailgate cook get
the charcoal going well congrats and
good luck in the future we've always
appreciated your time and thanks for
joining us guys
which damn great too always great to be
with you Bob Stoops the former Oklahoma
head coach Continental Tire coaches
corner from Sunday rain to snow and
everything in between Continental tires
engineer to tire for what you do they
want you the driver to have the traction
performance and comfort you require on
any road your travels may take you so
Continental Tire engineering tires with
extraordinary performance reliability
and putting confidence into driving more
information and the location of a dealer
near you Continental Tire calm cut none
no tire for what you do what stood out
there didn't rule out coaching again at
age 56 said that there's no smoking gun
maybe he would go into broadcasting
feels like it was a little bit of a
surprise there to his wife that he was
going to announce his retirement didn't
want to get into it but I felt like I
mean that's that's a quick decision on
something and to do it in June and he
didn't want to give me a timeline there
now I don't want to go all CSI on him
but it feels like at age 56 if it's not
health not NCAA violations not booster
pressure maybe you want to make sure
that you have the smooth transition to
your successor which he was able to do
and they get a young former assistant
coach in Lincoln Riley who was
considered an up-and-coming star that
transition happens it's smooth but a
year removed from signing a contract
extension after you go through the
recruiting process and then you got you
know just done with spring ball I don't
know the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you